اذا مشاهدينا اهلا بكم تغطيه مستمره ولكن
الاعين الان على موسكو تحديدا على
الكرملين والمعلومات التي تم اعلانها فيما
يتعلق بالناموسكو قامت الاجهزه فيها
الدفاعيه بتعطيل مسيرتين هاجمتا الكرملين
طبعا في تحدينا مباشر طبعا لروسيا طبعا
الكل كان يتوقع بالفتره الاخيره ما سمي
بالهجوم المضاد من قبل اوكرانيا على روسيا
الاعين كانت ايضا تتركز على بخمه حيث
العمليات مستمره هناك تقدم وتراجع من جهه
ما بين القوات المتقاتله الاوكرانيه
يقابلها الروسيه ولكن فيما يبدو بان
الضربات تستهدف قلب روسيا
وبينما كان العديد من المراقبين يتحدثون
ان التحشيد هو في تلك المناطق داخل
اوكرانيا في محاوله لضرب ان كان القوات
الروسيه او
الداعمه والمدعومه من قبل روسيا والتي
تقاتل على الارض خاصه في منطقه بخموت الا
ان التحركات فيما يبدو في اتجاه اخر تغيير
ربما في الاستراتيجيه التي تريد اوكرانيا
اتباعها في التعاطي مع الملف الروسي وما
تعتبره حرب عليها ان تنهيه الاستعاده
اراضيها بحسب اوكرانيا طبعا التوتر قائم
منذ فتره حتى على الحدود الروسيه
الاوكرانيه كان هناك منذ حوالي اليومين من
الان استهداف من الداخل الاوكراني لتلك
المنطقه وطبعا خلال فتره الاقتتال منذ
بدايته حتى هذا اليوم كانت هناك بعض
الضربات التي تصل الى الداخل الروسي ولكن
على الحدود كان هناك ايضا منذ حوالي
الشهرين صور لمضادات ارضيه في داخل
العاصمه الروسيه في حينها بانها اجراءات
تتبعها موسكو عاده نحن نعلم ان روسيا الان
بفتره مهمه من تاريخها تحتفل احتفالات
النصر وبالتالي من المتوقع وحسب ما راى
المراقبون وبعض التصريحات العسكريه كانت
تقول بان روسيا تقوم بتجهيز نفسها وحمايه
امنها القومي خوفا من اي ضربه ربما تستهدف
هذه الاحتفالات بعيد النصر كانت
التوقعات تشير الى امكانيه حدوث شيء ما
ولكن لم يتوقع اكد احد ان تصل الى قلب
العاصمه وتحديدا نتحدث عن تعطيل مسيرتين
يقال بان هاتين المسيرتين قد هاجم ذلك
لكريملين على كل معي من موسكو الدبلوماسي
السابق والمحلل السياسي
اهلا بك سيد بدايه اي معلومات حول ما تم
اعلانه الان هل لدينا تفاصيل
ولكن في وسائل الاعلام في انترنت هناك حتى
صور وحتى فيديو عن بعض الحرائق قريبه
لكريملين حتى في داخل موسكو وهناك اخبار
محاوله
الدائره طائرات اوكرانيه مسيره
تسقطوها او مش اسقطه اجبروا لي هبوط
قريبا من
مكان الوجود
وبيت الرئيس بوتين
انا هذا تحول
الجوهري في خوض المعرب في اوكرانيا بسبب
ان هناك كانت الهدوء
واتفاق غير الرسمي بين قياده اوكرانيه
وقياده روسيه ان لا يؤثر على مراكز
الاقامه الرئيس جاليانسكيبي اوكرانيا
وقياده الروسيه اليوم هذا محاوله
تستعمله طيرات
كانت ليست اول مره منذ اسبوعين او ثلاثه
كانت هناك اسقطه وجدوا مش اسقطه وجدوا
الاجزاء من الطائرات مسيره شرق في ضواحي
موسكو في شرقا ليست غربا
ولذلك
لا شك ان تزويد اوكرانيا بسلاح المعاشر
وخصوصا الصواريخ
مختلفه الانواع
وكذلك
المسيرات
وتكنولوجيات لصناعه طائرات المسيره كل
العوامل تزيد
حدد التوتر بين روسيا وامريكا في اوكرانيا
ولا شارك هذا يفرضوا على قياده الروسيه
ضروره اتخاذ القرار الاساسي
قبل قبل ان نتحدث عن الرد الروسي الان
لمثل هذا الخرق والتحول الجوهري كما وصفته
الاتفاق جنتل من ربما يمكن القول بين
وروسيا دعنا نتحدث عن تفاصيل ما نراه لا
اعلم ان كنت تشاهد الشاشه لانه نشاهد كنا
قبل قليل دخان يتصاعد وبالتالي ان تذكرت
بانه هناك معلومات تتحدث عن اكثر من منطقه
يتصاعد فيها الدخان او النيران هل لك ان
تحدد تلك المناطق ان كانت ما نشاهده الان
من ضمنها او لا
اولا انا الدخان سجلوا في مكان
وفي ضواحي حيث هناك المركز الاقامه لرئيس
بوتين في ظواهر هو غير موجود في هذه
المركز اما انتم عده المراكز الاقامه
وطبعا كل هذا الدليل على انه امريكا الرخص
وتشجع القوات الاوكرانيه لاننا نحن نعتبر
نقول عمليه العسكريه من جانب اوكرانيا هي
تحت قياده الدبات والقياده العسكريه
الامريكان والخبراء الامريكان تقول ان
الولايات المتحده قد تكون قد اعطت الضوء
الاخضر لاوكرانيا كي تصل الى مقربه من
منزل الرئيس الروسي وايضا لكريملين لماذا
برايك ولماذا الان
عكس طبيا هذا ليست من مصدر المعلومات كما
معلومات اما هذا من مركز التحاليل لان
نقول القرارات الرئيسيه
يتاقذوها امريكا
من خلال متابعتك وتحليلك وقراءتك للمشهد
لماذا قد تكون الولايات المتحده بعد كل
هذه الفتره مستعده للوصول الى مثل هذا
التصعيد الى قلب العاصمه روسيا واستفزاز
الرئيس الروسي شخصيا
القرارات ضمن القرار العام بدا الهجوم
الاساسي لقوات اوكرانيه على روسيا وعلى
قوات الروسيه في دونيسكو
وكريسون وذلك
هذا الخطه العامه هناك التحذير
يعتبرون في روسيا خبر
اء
مايو 18 او
لا اعرف ولكن
يتحدثون عن اقصى شيء
18 من شهر تجاري لذلك انا تصور انه تمنع
هذا الخطه العامه هناك
محاولات استفزازيه
استدراكيه مثلا غاره
جويه بمسيارات الطائرات المسيره في قرن ان
عمله ضربه على على مستودع مصنع
في القرن وكذلك
بس هناك فرق هناك هناك فرق سيد فيجسلاف
ما بين استهداف القرم لاوكرانيا تعتبرها
جزء من اراضيها وما بين استهداف الاراضي
الروسيه وتحديدا الوصول الى منزل الرئيس
الروسي
لا اعلم ان كان لدينا اي معلومات نشاهد
هذه الصور للرئيس
الروسي لا اعلم صور مسجله طبعا ولكن نحاول
ان نعرف ما الذي يحدث في الشارع الان
وردود الفعل سيد فيتش سلاف لم تعطيني
قراءه حول تحديد التوقيت الان لمثل هذا
التصعيد الان وان كان فعلا من مصلحه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
استفزاز الرئيس الروسي الذي استخدم عباره
السلاح النووي اكثر من مره خلال الفتره
الماضيه ايضا من جانبه قال لا تختبروا
روسيا بهذا الاطار
ليست بين روسيا واوكرانيا هذا استدامه
احادي الروسي امام سياسه الامريكيه على
صعيد العالمي وليست ال سعيد الاوكراني
وليس هذا الصراع الاقليمي هذا استدام على
مستوى العالمي بين روسيا كانت تتحدى
امريكا
بسياساتها الخارجيه بشكل عام
سياسه
القطب الواحد
ولذلك انا اتصور ان كل ما يجري الان يطلب
من روسيا الذي كان مطلوب سابقا ولكن قياده
العسكريه روسيه قياده سياسيه روسيه امتنعت
ان توجيه اي ضربات الصاروخيه على مراكز
الاقامه رئيس اوكرانيا
اركان الحرب الاوكرانيه وزاره الدفاع
اوكرانيه يعني والمراكز نقليات
الحديث متطوره في اوكرانيا كثيرا وينتقلون
الصواريخ وتبابات على سكه الحديد في
اوكرانيا بكل سهوله من غرب الى مناطق
شرقيه مناطق
مناطق
استدامه
مصلح ولذلك انا اتصور انا طبيعه
معركه تتغير تتغير سبب لها واحد انا
امريكا لم تتحلى على اي محاوله ان يوجهوا
الضرب الهزيمه كامله على روسياراليه ولذلك
لديك قياده اوكرانيه لا يوجد خيار هناك في
الموقف الاميركي واضح تماما لقياده
الروسيه انهم مصممين ان يوقنوا ولكن توازن
على الارض
اوازن في الميدان القوه العسكريه بين
اوكرانيا وروسيا واوكرانيا حتى
كل دعم الدول الغربيه اكثر من خمسين دوله
تشارك في تزويد جيشكريني بسلاح طبعا توازن
على الميدان ليست لمسلحه
اوكرانيا لاشاك ولكن بغض النظر عن كل هذه
الحسابات
امريكا تشجع تشجع
ايضا انه ربما تكون هذه الضربه بضوء اكثر
من الولايات المتحده ولكن اسمح لي ان اشير
الى هذه الصور التي نشرها الكريم قبل قليل
طبعا يظهر من خلال هذه الصور شوارع
العاصمه
وتحرك طبيعي للسيارات هناك اضافه الى صور
تظهر الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ربما
في اشاره الى ان هو ليس متواجد في منزله
حيث كان هناك محاوله
للاستهداف او رصد الطائرات مسيره في تلك
المنطقه في ضواحي العاصمه موسكو اضافه الى
ذلك بانه يقوم باداء عمله خلال هذه الفتره
على كل اعود اليك بعد قليل سيد فيجسلاف
ولكن اسمح لي ان انتقل الى مراسله العربيه
من موسكو كاتيا طعمي اهلا بك كاتيا ما
المعلومات المتوفره لديك كاتيا
مرحبا ميسون بالفعل كان الكرملين اليوم
كان قد تحدث عن هجوم لمسيرتين كما قال
انها من الجانب الاوكراني اتهم الجانب
الاوكراني بمحاوله اغتيال الرئيس الروسي
من خلال هجمات نفذتها ليلا اليوم كانت قد
طبعا تحدثت ان القوات الروسيه والقوات
الاستخباراتيه قامت باسقاط هذه المسيرات
خلال الهجوم لذلك لم يتسنى لهذه المسيرات
بتنفيذ العمليه حتى النهايه ولكن كان هناك
طبعا كما تظهر بعض الصور التي تناقلتها
وسائل الاعلام الروسيه عنك عن وجود حريق
على سطح الكريم ليلا نتيجه طبعا الشظايا
ونتيجه
انتجابتين اسمحي لي كونك تتحدثين عن هذه
النقطه وصلتنا الان الصور التي تظهر لحظه
الهجوم طبعا
هذا الهجوم الذي يعتبر بانه محاوله
الاغتيال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين تم
تحطيم المسيرتين اللتين حاولت تنفيذ هذه
العمليه كاتيا تفضلي
نعم ميسون بالفعل هاتين المسيرتين تم
تحطيمها من قبل القوات الروسيه
والاستخباراتيه والقوات العسكريه
الرادارات قامت برصد هاتين المسيرتين
واسقاطهما الشظايا طبعا سقطت ولم يكن هناك
ضحايا ولكن فقط الحريق الذي تناقلت صوره
وسائل الاعلام الروسيه على السطح الكرملين
طبعا ميسون هذا هذا الهجوم اليوم هو الاول
من نوعه ان تصل هذه المسيرات الى الكرملين
لم تحدث هذه الحادثه من قبل هذه اول مره
تصل المسيرات الاوكرانيه كما تقول روسيا
ان هذه المسيرات هي اطلقها الجانب
الاوكراني على خلفيه كل الحادث كان قد
تحدث عمده موسكو عن منع
استخدام المسيرات فوق العاصمه الروسيه
بالاخص نحن على ابواب احتفالات عيد النصر
التي ستعود اليك الى الحديث اكثر
وهذا ساعود اليك للحديث اكثر عن الوضع في
داخل
العاصمه والاحتفالات هذه ولكن اسمحي لي
معي من كييف يا فهيم ميك تينكو وهو مستشار
وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني اهلا بك سيد يفين
روسيا تتهمكم مباشره بمحاوله اغتيال
الرئيس الروسي مدى تردون
اهلا وسهلا بكم تحيه من كيف كيف مشمسه
وكيب عادي الان ولكن بالليله هذه
بدعه ليالي قبل ايام كانت هاديه وهناك كان
هجوم من مسيرات شهيد
الايرانيات ايرانيه يعني بعشرات
ولكن سؤال الان عن العاصمه الروسيه موسكو
اي دليل بانها مسيرات الاوكرانيه او تم
اطلاقها من اوكرانيا لسه مش مؤكد كما
تعرفون الان سيد الرئيس زياره رسميه
فنلندا وما سمعتش اي تاكيدات بان مسيرات
اوكرانيه
ولكن عندما بدات الحديث بدات الحديث وكانك
كنت تريد ان تقول بانه ما حدث في كييف
ربما يحتاج الى رد قد يصل الى هذه النقطه
هل هذا ما اردته
مواطنين من جيل بس من مدن اخرى اوديسا
وخارقه
نحن متعودين على
هجمات من مسيرات وهجمات من
صواريخ كروز
يوميا او حتى كل ثاني يوم فهاي حياتنا
الحرب هي الحرب مين شم الحرب
جارنا ولكن حدودها الجغرافيه
سيدي ياهين حدودها الجغرافيه كانت معروفه
وهي اوكرانيا هل نحن نتحدث الان عن
امكانيه توسيع جغرافيه الحرب الان
والله ممكن نتحدث بنا الحرب هي الحرب وفي
الحرب يهدا كل شيء ممكن كل شيء وراء احد
يعرف ممكن وصلتنا مسيرات طويله المدى ممكن
لكن انا ما سمعتش عن ذلك وهل يمكن السر
يعني حتى مش للكل مش
للمشل لكل بيعرض هذا
وكما تعرفون الان يدور الحديث حول الهجوم
المضاد الاوكراني المحتمل امتى في اي
اتجاه ولا احد يعرف ولا احد يعرف هاي
حياتنا هاي حياتنا منذ اكثر من 14 ارجل
من حياه الحرب ولكن سيد يفهم هناك ربما
ضوابط معينه عاده بالحروب هناك
جغرافيات تحدد على الاقل ان لم تكن علنا
ولكن بشكل ضمني ما بين الدول هناك
حمراء لا يمكن تخطيها وربما تكون قضيه
الوصول الى قلب العاصمه موسكو او اغتيال
رئيس دوله من الخطوط الحمر المعروفه والا
لو لم يكن هناك من خطوط حمر ربما كانت
روسيا قد استهدفت الرئيس الاوكراني
وبالتالي السؤال الان الى اي حد اوكرانيا
مستعده لمثل هذا التوسع في الحرب اذا مصح
وهل يمكن لها ان تتحرك دون ضوء اخضر من
الولايات المتحده
زي ما انا قريته سمعت بان اوكرانيا ما
تخابر لا تخابر بعد من الدول الحليفه
حول الختت الهجوم المحتمل لاوكرانيا اولا
وثانيا هاي كل تصريحات انا ما سمعتش
ولسه ما سمعت شيء تسريحات من وسائل
الاعلام ولا من شخصيات الاوكرانيه العليا
فيما يخص هجوم عاصمه روسيا وهجوم صاحب
الكرملين ابدا ما سمعتش واذا ما صح ذلك هل
يمكن لاوكرانيا ان تتحرك دون تنسيق مع
الحلفاء بغض النظر عن اطلاعهم من عدم
اطلاعهم عن اي خطه او خطوه تقوم بها ولكن
عندما نتحدث عن تحول
جوهري في طريقه الصراع والحرب ما بين
الدولتين على الاقل الدول المشاركه
والحليفه لها الاحقيه في معرفه ذلك هل
يمكن لي اوكرانيا ان تتحرك دون التواصل مع
الولايات المتحده تحديدا والحلفاء الاخرين
بصوره عامه
لا احد يريد ان تتوسع الحرب
واما خطوات لطرف ما هاي خطوات متفقه على
مستوى العليا على مستوى السياسيه وعلى
مستوى عسكريه
فخليهم يستعملون ويعملون ونحن ننتظر طيب
تنتظر ماذا وماذا تتوقعون ان يكون الرد
الروسي وهل يمكن بغض النظر عن ان كانت
اوكرانيا هي التي ارسلت المسيرتين او لم
تقم بارسالهما
ان تتوقع ردود الفعل الروسيه هل هي مستعده
لذلك
ردود فعل روسيا يعني نحن في انتظارها في
اي لا لان على يقين يعني كل قواتنا وخصيصا
قوات مضاده للصواريخ والدفاع الجوي على
استهداف كامل 24 ساعه كل يوم ان لم تكن
اوكرانيا مفاجات طيب اما
من جانبنا ستاتي كمان لكن في وقت المناسب
وهذه النقطه الرئيسيه من من مصلحته الان
ان لم تكن اوكرانيا وراء هذه العمليه
ومحاوله اغتيال الرئيس الروسي من من
مصلحته اشعال المنطقه بهذه الطريقه
خلينا ننتظر تسريحات لشخصيات رسميه
اوكرانيا وروسيا وبعدين
نشوف النتائج
يعني ماذا يحدث التصريحات الاوليه توجه
اصاحب اصابع الاتهام مباشره الى اوكرانيا
وليس فقط في استهداف موسكو بصوره عامه
ولكن بمحاوله فاشله لاغتيال الرئيس الروسي
انا لسه انا الان في الشارع في كيف وانا
اتجول في كيف الان
ولسه ما سمعتش هاي تسريحات للاسف الشديد
او الحمد لله ما سمعتش طيب على كل س ننتظر
حتى تعود ربما الى المنزل وتتابع التطورات
وربما يكون لديك الوقت للتواصل مع
القيادات الاوكرانيه لمعرفه الموقف الرسمي
لانه بحسب ما فهمت انت لم تعطينا اي تصريح
رسمي لا نفي ولا ايجاب انت لا تعرف من قام
بهذه العمليه يعني لا تنسي ربما تكون
خلينا ننتظر خلينا ننتظر الجواب من شخصيات
القائده يعني من قاده البلاد والنقطه
الاساسيه اذا ما قرانا بالمشهد تبعات مثل
هذه الضربه ان لم تكن اوكرانيا قد فعلتها
او لم تفعلها ماذا تتوقع نفهم بانكم
تعودتم على ردود الفعل الروسيه ولكن في
اطار الحرب القائمه ولكن في اطار تجاوز
الخطوط الحمر ان كان من خلال اوكرانيا او
غيرها ماذا نتوقع اكثر مما حدث اصلا انا
قلت لك الان انا تجاول في في عاصمه
اوكرانيا مدينه كيف عاصمه يعني
ربية وكل شيء جميل وهناك الشمس والناص
المرتحين ويبتسمون برغم كل شيء برغم
يبتسموه ويا مليون
لا نستعجل تعرفي من من فين او من وين
مستشار وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني شكرا
جزيلا لك وهذه عوده الى مراسله العربيه
كاتيا تعميق كاتيا نشاهد هذه الصور الى
اعلم ان كنت تتابعين الشاشه الان او
متواجده على الارض ولكن نشاهد هذه الصور
التي وردتنا للاستهداف الفاشل لمسيرتين
طبعا وبحسب الكريم
الرئيس الروسي مباشره كان هناك دخان نار
يتصاعد من جهه اخرى لا اعلم ان كنا نشاهد
نفس المنطقه ولكن من زوايا مختلفه ام انه
بالفعل كان هناك اكثر من استهداف كاتيا
ميسون بالفعل تتناقل وسائل الاعلام الان
بكثافه لعده فيديوهات تظهر اولا لحظه هجوم
المسيرات على الكرملين والحريق الذي نجم
فيما بعد نتيجه سقوط هذه المسيرات هناك
اكثر من فيديو حتى اللحظه لا نعلم حقيقه
ان كانت هذه المصادر الفيديو هي رسميه ام
كانت فعلا تم تصويرها من قبل
الماره هناك لانه كما تعلمين ميسون هذه
الحادثه وقعت ليلا كما قال الكريم
امس لذلك حتى الان لا نعلم ان كانت تم
تصويرها بالفعل من قبل كرملين نفسه او هي
صور الكاميرات المراقبه حول الكريم او
انها تم تصويرها من قبل الماره من جانب
الكريملين في الليل طبعا كما تحدث الكريم
متحدث الرسمي باسم الرئيس الروسي قال ان
هناك سيكون طبعا من جانب الروسي رد على
هذا الهجوم
على الكريم ومحاوله استهداف الرئيس الروسي
سيكون هناك رد بتاكيد لمقال ولكن هي تحتفظ
طبعا
بحق الرد او بطريقه الرد التي ستقوم
بها موسكو على اوكرانيا لم يكشف لنا عن
طبيعه هذا الرجل الذي يكون سيكون من قبل
موسكو وبالاخص ان هذه هذه المسيره يعني
لاول مره تدخل العاصمه الروسيه موسكو
ميسون هي طبعا تستهدف الكريم
قد يكون اشاره او اعاقه لعمليه تنظيم عيد
النصر والذي هو طبعا بالنسبه لروسيا مهم
لمحاربه النازيه شعار محاربه النازيه التي
هي بالاساس بدات العمليه العسكريه كما
تقول لمحاربه النازيه في اوكرانيا طبعا
هذه المحاوله هي ضمن محاولات مكثفه نشهدها
خلال الايام الاخيره لمحاولات استهداف
روسيا سواء كانت في المناطق الحدوديه في
شبه جزيره القرم كان هناك استهداف
لمناطق
مثل استهداف مستودع للنفط بالاضافه لذلك
كان هناك استهداف لمدينه كان هناك زرع
عبوات ناسفه وقطع طرق للسكك الحديديه على
مدى يومين قطارات كانت تحمل النفط قطارات
بيلاروسيا تحمل النفط من روسيا لذلك هناك
حمله مكثفه نشادها خلال هذه الفتره واخرها
هي هذه هذا الاستهداف لوسط عاصم العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو وهو طبعا اشاره وهو خطوه
طبعا تعتبر تاجيجيه كما يعتبرها الخبراء
ان كانت فعلا قد خرجت من الجانب الاوكراني
ميسون
قبل قليل ضيفي كان يتحدث عن ان هناك في
شرق موسكو وجدت بعض الاجزاء ايضا مسيره
اخرى قبل حوالي اليومين من الان لا اعلم
ان كان لديك اي معلومات عن هذه النقطه
الاستهداف المسيرات العاصمه الروسيه موسكو
كان هناك حادثه استهدفت ضواحي موسكو وليس
العاصمه الروسيه وليس وسط موسكو كان هناك
استهداف
لمستودع للنفذ في ضواحي موسكو وطبعا تم
تدمير هذه المسيره ولم تقوم
بتفجير المنطقه المستهدفه ولكن كعاصمه
روسيه او كقلب العاصمه الروسيه هو
الاستهداف الاول من نوعه لمسيره لا نعلم
حتى الان ولم يتم الحديث من قبل ان اطلقت
هذه المسيرات من داخل العاصمه الروسيه
موسكو او انها اتت فعلا من الجانب
الاوكراني وقطعت مسافات هائله لانه كما
تعلمين منذ قليل كان قد تحدث عن عمده
موسكو عن منع
اطلاق المسيرات في فوق العاصمه الروسيه
موسكو وهذا ياتي خلفيه على خلفيه هذه
الحادثه اولا وقبيله طبعا
احتفالات عيد النصر التي سيحضرها الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بنفسه كما قال
انه لا يوجد اي تغيير في الخطط لحضور رئيس
الروسي او لاقامه هذه الاحتفالات التي
ستقام طبعا يوم التاسع من مايو المقبل وفي
العاصمه موسكو هناك تحضيرات امنيه
وتعزيزات امنيه استعدادا لمثل هذا الحفل
او حتى قبل ذلك كنا شاهدنا بفتره من
الفترات صور لمضادات موجوده في قلب
العاصمه الروسيه هل لك ان تضعين بصوره
الوضع امنيا وبالمقابل طبعا بيان الكرملين
يتحدث انه لم يصب احد جراء سقوط الشظايا
وتناثر الشظايا ان كان على السيارات او لم
تكن هناك ايضا اضرار لا ماديه ولا بشريه
تفضلي كاتيا
ميسون دعيني ابدا اولا من انه الكريملين
كان قد وجه له سؤال منذ ايام حول
الاجراءات الامنيه التي سيتخذها يوم عيد
النصر وان كان هناك توقعات لتنفيذ هجمات
من قبل الاجانب الاوكراني وهذا لم يستثنيه
طبعا انه يتوقع ان يكون هناك هجمات وان
روسيا تقوم بالاستعداد امنيا لطبعا لرد اي
هجوم من قبل اجانب الاوكراني اذا هناك كان
توقعات بان يحدث عمليات استفزازيه قبيله
عيد النصر طبعا قبيله عيد النصر العاصمه
الروسيه وبالتحديد هنا تحدث عن الساحه
الحمراء يتم تطويقها بشكل كامل ومنع طبعا
سير الحركه المروريه بجانب العاصمه
الروسيه او عفوا الساحه الحمراء طبعا هذا
السماح بدخول فيما بعد
التقنيات والدبابات التي ستقوم بالتدريب
قبيله بدء الاحتفالات يوم التاسع من من
التاسع المقبل طبعا هذه
الاستعدادات الامنيه هي تبدا قبيله
الاحتفالات بفتره طويله من جانب ومن جانب
اخر طبعا روسيا كانت وعلى خلفيه هجوم
المسيرات المكثفه التي تشهده روسيا
باكملها كانت قد قامت العاصمه الروسيه
موسكو بزرع انظمه الدفاع الجوي في كافه في
محيط العاصمه الروسيه موسكو في جميع
المناطق في بما في ذلك ايضا مبنى وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه التي طبعا كانت قد انتشرت
صور لفيديو انها قامت بنشر انظمه دفاع
جويه على سطح هذه المباني بالاضافه الى
اسطح مباني اخرى هي تعود الى مؤسسات
حكوميه لذلك الميسون طبعا هناك تجديد امني
قبيله عيد النصر وبالاخص الان بعد هذا
الحادث سيكون هناك اكيد تجديدات امنيه
موسعه من اجل التحضير لاحتفالات عيد النصر
التي ستقام خلال الايام المقبله معنا عود
اليك بعد قليل ولكن معي من اكياف الصحفي
محمد البابا اهلا بك محمد بدايه كيف هي
اصداء ما نشر حتى الان حول محاوله لاغتيال
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
يعني حتى هذه اللحظه اللي هي تعليق رسمي
من اي جهه رسميه اوكرانيه ولكن بحسب
الوقائع هذا تطور خطير
وينقل المعركه الى ناحيه اخرى خاصه ان
يعتبر من الخطوط الحمراء واستهداف الكريم
بما حصل وكما راينا هناك احد السينيران
يعني كنت اتحدث قبل دقائق مع احد
المستشارين في وزاره الخارجيه الذي نفى
اولا ان يكون هناك ان تكون اوكرانيا او لا
معلومات حتى هذه اللحظه ان تكون اي جهه
اوكرانيه الجيش الاوكراني او حتى
الاستقلال الاوكرانيه وراء هذه العمليه
وينتظرون الدليل الذي يعني الادله التي
ستقدمها موسكو لترد عليها السلطات
الاوكرانيه بما هي ولكن هناك احد
السينيرهان الذي يتم الحديث عنه اولا ربما
قد تكون وهذا يعني من تحليلات شخصيه ربما
تكون هذه العمليه هي حركه استباقيه لتعقير
الجو في موسكو خاصه اننا في الاسبوع الذي
يشبه عيد النصر وخاصه في موسكو في هذه
هناك اجراءات امنيه مشدده وتعتبر هذه خرق
امني كبير يعني الامن الروسي للامن الخاص
للرئيس بوتين وللكرملين خاصه الاستهداف
بهذه الطريقه مسيره تم اطلاقها من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه اي ما يفوق الالف عبرت هذه
المسيره وخرقت جميع الدفاعات الجويه ووصلت
الى هدفها وتم استهدافها او اسقاطها قبل
الان يعني قبل حوالي امتار قليله من سقف
الكريم او مكتب بوتين هذا يعتبر خارق امني
كبير السيناريو الاخر الذي يتم الحديث عنه
ويتجاوز في وسائل الاعلام الاوكرانيه
ووسائل التواصل الاجتماعي انها ربما حركه
من الاجانب الروسي لتشويه الهجوم المضاد
ويعني خالق تصعيد كبير قبل او سباقا
للهجوم المضاده التي تعد له اوكرانيا
ويتداول انه ربما في التاسع من ماي او في
في يوم عيد النصر لذلك هذين السيناريوهين
يتم الحديث عنه ولكن لا ننتظر اي موقف
رسمي من اوكرانيا عاده اوكرانيا عندما تمت
يعني عمليات كثيره في العمق الروسي بالقرب
من العاصمه موسكو تم استهداف مطارين
عسكريين لم تتبنى اوكرانيا ولم يصدر اي
بيان رسمي من الجانب الاوكراني يتبنى هذه
العمليات وحتى يعني صباح هذا اليوم كان
هناك معلومات ان روسيا والمستخبارات
الروسيه قد
اوقفت او عطلت شبكه للقيام بعمليات
ارهابيه ايضا حتى هذه اللحظه صباح اليوم
حتى هذه اللحظه لا يوجد اي موقف رسمي من
الجانب الاوكراني ينفي او يتبنى هذه
العمليات وحتى قبل يعني عندما استهدفت
يعني تم استهداف او تفجير لجسر قرش او جسر
القرن لم يكن هناك موقف رسمي من اوكرانيا
يتبنى او يخفي هذه العملي ولكن بغض النظر
محمد ان كانت اوكرانيا وراء هذه العمليه
في روسيا قالت بانها سترد وان لم تكن وكان
هذا السيناريو الذي يطرح البعض حركه من
قبل روسيا لتشويه الهجوم المضادفه لها
امكانيه بان ترد مع عذر كبير بانه عاصمتها
تم استهدافها ورئيسها في محاوله فاشله
لاغتياله وبالتالي ما هي الاستعدادات
الامنيه ان كان هناك اي شيء تلمستموه في
العاصمه كيف
حتى هذه اللحظه يعني العاصمه الاوكرانيه
يعني الحياه عاديه
الطرقات الطقس مش مش كما ذكر يعني
قبل دقائق من الان ان الوضع هادئ في
اوكرانيا هناك يعني ترقب حذر بعد هذه
المعلومات ولا ننسى ليله امس كان هناك
استهداف للعاصمه الاوكرانيه معجم يعني من
الساعه الواحده حتى الرابعه صباحا كنا
نسمع اصوات انفجارات وهي الدفاعات الجويه
التي الان يعني منذ حوالي اسبوعين او
ثلاثه اسابيع
هيستنفار عام في محيط العاصمه الاوكرانيه
ومعظم يعني الاهداف الجويه التي كانت
تستهدف العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف كان يتم
اسقاطها بشكل كامل ما يعني ان المنظومات
باتريوت انها تعمل الان بفاعليه كبيره
لحمايه يعني العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف من
جامع من جميع الجهات حتى هذه اللحظه ترقب
حذر في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف ننتظر
يعني وربما غير الرسميه او الرئويه رد فعل
من الجانب الاوكراني بتصري ح او بيان
وسنخبركم فورا بهذه التفاصيل الان ننتظر
الاعلام في اوكرانيا مع هذا الحدث الكبير
وبالمقابل هل استطعتم تلمس ردود فعل
الشارع هل الشارع معني بتوسيع رقعه الحرب
هذه لتصل الى قلب العاصمه موسكو او لا
يعني الجميع هناك نوعين هناك فئه من الناس
هي راضيه عن اداء القوات الاوكرانيه
وتعتبر ان كان جيش الاوكراني قد او اي جهه
اوكرانيه او السلطات الاوكرانيه قد قامت
بهذا العمل هذا انتصار كبير ان تستطيع
مسيره اطلقت من اوكرانيا ان تعبر الف كيلو
متر وتصل الى بالقرب من هدفها هذا خرج
واثبات ان التطور الاوكراني وتطور الجيش
الاوكراني هو في مسار جيد في الجانب الاخر
من الراي العام الاوكراني يتخوف من رده
فعل الجانب الروسي خاصه يعني قبل سبعه
اشهر بعد استهداف جسر القلم والذي كان
يعتبر من الخطوط الحمر كان هناك رده فعل
عنيفه قالت الشعب الاوكراني بالدرجه
الاولى عندما قامت روسيا باستهداف يعني
المحطات الطاقه محطات الكهرباء عان الشعب
الاوكراني خلال فصل الشتاء من انقطاع
التيار الكهربائي من حاله البدء البرد بعد
استهداف المحطات المدنيه ومحطات التدفئه
لذلك الان جميع متخوف من ماذا ستكون الفعل
الروسيه وكيف ستكون كيف نوعيتها هل ستكون
بضربات صاروخيه اوكرانيا اصبحت متطوره في
الدفاع الجوي الى حد ما هل سيكون هناك
هجوم بري قد يسبق الهجوم المضاده الذي
تقوم به اوكرانيا وهذا ايضا يتداول في
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ننتظر يعني كيف
ستكون رده الفعل الاوكرانيه حول اتهام
اوكرانيا بهذه العمليه وكيف ستكون رده
الفعل الروسيه على هذه العمليه
طبعا من اكياف الصحفي محمد البابا شكرا
جزيلا لك وينضم الي الان من موسكو الكاتب
السياسي بسام البني اهلا بك سيد بسام
بدايه قراءتك لهذا المشهد وقبل قليل كنا
نتحدث عن سيناريو يدعم روايه روسيا من ان
اوكرانيا وراء هذا الاستهداف وسيناريو اخر
يتحدث عن انه لا ربما تكون روسيا ارادت ان
تشوه صوره الهجوم المضاد وبالتالي قامت
بهذه العمليه الفاشله تفضل
اسعد الله اوقاتك استاذ ميسون واوقات
مشاهدين قناه العربيه الكرام يعني اولا
استطيع ان امفي بشكل قاطع ان تكون روسيا
قد قامت بهذا العمل لاسباب عديده وهي انها
على ابواب 9 مايو ولا يمكن لها ان تشوه هي
سمعتها بانها لم تستطيع ان تصدي لهذه
المسيرات التي قدمت الى موسكو سواء من
اوكرانيا او من داخل موسكو او من اطراف
موسكو من ضواحيها
وقبل امتار قليله من سقف كما ذكر السيد
محمد قبل قليل تم يعني تفجيرها هذا يعني
اننا امام سيناريو واحد وهو ان اوكرانيا
وراء هذه الجمال سواء عن طريق خليه
ارهابيه نائمه موجوده داخل موسكو او
ضواحيها او من خلال ارسال مسيره من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه
اشعال المزيد من الازمات وتوسيع الرقعه
الان ما بين اوكرانيا وروسيا بالنسبه
للحرب
الطرف الثالث هو بولندا
وبريطانيا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الصقور في الجهه الاخرى التي تدفع
اوكرانيا للهجوم المضاد ولكن روسيا تنتظر
هذا الهجوم واوكرانيا يبدو لي انها لا
تريد القيام بهذا الهجوم لانها تعلم انه
هجوم فاشل وان الهجوم يعني يجب ان يكون
لديها سلاسل مقابل واحد المدافع يكون اقل
عددا من المهاجم وخسائر المهاجم اكبر من
خسائر المدافع بعد الخسائر التي تعرضت لها
في
يعني لا يمكنها ان تفشل مره اخرى وان قامت
بهجوم مضاد وفشل ستبقى كالحقيبه بلايات
بالنسبه للغرب لم
يعني مؤلم وحملها متعب لذلك
ستكون وراء هذه العمليه الان اشعر وراء
كانك تقول بانه الولايات المتحده وايضا
بولندا وبريطانيا ربما تكون هذه الدول هي
من تريد اشعال المزيد من الحرائق فهل يمكن
ان تقوم اوكرانيا تحت الضغط اذا مصحه
تعبير بالقيام بمثل هذه العمليه او انها
لا تدري بالفعل
بكل تاكيد هي تقوم بهذه العمليه بالنتيجه
ضغط غربي عليها لان الغرب قال ان يعني على
لسان بعيدا على ما اعتقد قال نحن قدمنا
حوالي ميه بالميه مما طلبته كيف من اجل
الهجوم المضاد اذا اذهبي وقومي بالهجوم
المضاد
يعني هجوم فاشل هجوم فاشل لم تستفد منه
شيء الان الا برد روسي وتوعد بانها سترد
وبقوه اعتقد اعتقد انه اوكرانيا تعتقد ان
هذا الهجوم استفزازي بكل معنى الكلمه
وروسيا لن تنتظر الهجوم المضاده تقوم هي
بالهجوم هذا ما يدعم نظريتي حول ان
اوكرانيا لا تقوم هي لا تريد القيام هي
بالهجوم المضاد تريد لروسيا ان تقوم بهجوم
وتتكبر روسيا خسائر ومن ثم ينظر الى
الخارطه العسكريه كيف تبنى انا باعتقادي
الشخصي سينتظر ستنتظر موسكو حتى قدوم
زينين بعودته من فنلندا وسيتم استهداف
مكان اقامته كما تم استهداف مكان اقامه
بوتين وغير ذلك لا اعتقد ان روسيا ستغسل
ماء وجهها اذا لم تفعله على كل هناك تعليق
الانسكي على تويتر يقول فيها كلما ضغطنا
على المعتدي كلما انتهى العدوان وبشكل
اسرع لا اعلم ان كان في قراءه لهذه الجمله
على ان اوكرانيا وراء هذه العمليه وان
كانت فاشله سيد بسام
انا اعتقد انه يعلم تماما انه اوكرانيا
وراء هذه العمليه لاغتيال بوتين الفاشله
لان هو موجود في في عندما يعود سيكون مضطر
للعيش في الملجا يعني هذا امر واقع واضح
للعيان اما عن رده فعل روسيا اللي بيعيش
بيشوف انا اعتقد انه ستكون هناك هجمه
صاروخيه مشدده وكبيره يعني يستهدف بها
اهداف لم تستهدف من قبل على سبيل المثال
وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه مكان اقامه الرئيسي لانسكي الى
اخره وقد تقوم روسيا باستهداف ايضا الحدود
البولنديه الاوكرانيه مكان تجمع الاسلحه
التي يقوم الغرب بتزويدها لاوكرانيا فنحن
في حاله حرب وقد صرح الكريم مرارا وتكرارا
اننا ننتظر عمليات ارهابيه وقد قلت انا
منذ يومين ان روسيا تعتبر انه
الحاله الخطره والحرجه في العمليه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا هي بين خمسه الى 12
مايو الجاري نتيجه
الانتظار
المرتقب للهجوم المضاد الاوكراني او
للهجوم الروسي على كراماتورس بعد ان تحررت
ضخمه من القوات الاوكرانيه
عبد الجواد الرشد فقط اريد التعليق عندما
تقول انه الان استهدافات ستكون مختلفه جدا
عن السابق وذكرت وزاره الدفاع وغيرها هل
انت تقول انه الان من الوجهه النظر
الروسيه اصبح الرئيس الاوكراني هدف مشروع
بالنسبه لها
هذا الاستهداف الفاشل لحياه الرئيس بوتين
في الكرملين اقصى حرق يدي روسيا
طريقتين في استهداف اي هدف تريده فهي تملك
الحق الاخلاقي في استهداف اي هدف يعني
متغاضي بغض النظر عن الحقيقه التي ذكرتيها
حضرتك مع الاستاذه عندما كنت تتحدثين عن
الموضوع الاخلاقي والاتفاق الضمني او
الغير معلم بين الدول في حاله حروب بعدم
استخدام يعني استهداف مثلا رؤساء الدول او
شيء من هذا القبيل اليوم روسيا عليها ان
تفهم انها في حاله حرب حقيقيه وليس في
حاله عمليه عسكريه خاصه العمليه العسكريه
خاصه لا تستخدم رؤساء الدول بينما الحرب
تستهدف
جاء من قائد فاجنر يقول بانه يعتقد هجوم
اوكرانيا المضاد قد بدا بالفعل طبعا بعد
ما تم الاعلان عنه الان من هذا الاستهداف
ابقى معي سيدي ولكن اسمح لي ان انتقل لعبد
الجواد الرشد مراسل العربيه متواجد معي في
الاستوديو عبد الجواد هل لك ان تعطينا
صوره عما نشاهده الان هذه الصور هذه
النيران التي تتصاعد والاستهداف ما الذي
تمثله شرح للصوره لو سمحت مرحبا ميسون نعم
بالفعل يعني ما تم تداوله على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي بشكل كبير او على
الوكالات وما نلاحظه الان عبر شاشتنا هي
بعض لقطات الفيديو هذا الفيديو الاول طبعا
قام بنشره الكرملين رسميا طبعا هذه
الكاميرا هي كاميرا مثبته تقع في مبنى
يعني المجمع التجاري الكوم المواجه
للكريمن هي الجهه الغربيه لجدار الكريميل
كما نلاحظ بان طائره الدرون تاتي من الجهه
الغربيه وتتجه نحو المبنى الرئيس في
الكرملين طبعا ان كان الصوت يساعدنا نوعا
ما لابد من ملاحظه او سماع صوت انفجارين
طبعا هذا الشيء من يعني من تواجدنا على
الخط الفاصل بين الاراضي الروسيه
والاوكرانيه كنا نلاحظ دوما يعني حينما
تعمل اجهزه الدفاع الجوي تسمعين انفجارين
ميسون يعني
الصباح والجو يعني السماء تبدو
يعني الغيوم تبدو قليله في سماء موسكو
وهذا الشيء كان ملاحظ ايضا في الفيديو
الذي نشره الكرملين عند المساء ما يعني
بان طبعا الطوق الامني يجب ان يعمل بشكل
جيد في موسكو لا وجود للغيوم او الامطار
بشكل سليم اليس كذلك نعم ميسون يعني من
الانفجار ومن لون النار الذي خرج من
الانفجار هو اصطدام صاروخ الدفاع الجوي
بطائره الدرون لكن القبه في الكرملين يعني
وهي وهو المبنى الرئيس تبدو الان في هذا
الفيديو بشكل واضح
وهذا لونها الحقيقي يعني في اي تاثير هذا
لونه الحقيقي طبعا الكثير من الفيديوهات
انتشرت على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي قام
بتصويرها بعض سكان المنطقه على ما يبدو من
الجو بان هذه الحادثه وقعت يعني بعد
الثالثه ليلا باعتبار ان الشمس بدات يعني
اضواءها تصل الى الارض او نورها نوعا ما
يعني هو الجو واضح الان في موسكو كما يظهر
من مقاطع الفيديو لكن طبعا المضمون ميسون
هو ليست هي المره الاولى التي تصل فيها
طائرات درون او طائرات من دون طيار الى
الداخل الروسي والى عمق المدن الروسيه لكن
الشيء الخطير اليوم هو وصول هذه الطائرات
من دون طيار الى العاصمه موسكو وبالتحديد
الى مبنى هذا الحادث ياتي طبعا قبل ايام
على عيد النصر وهو عيد كبير ومقدس وهذا
يدفعني للتساؤل عن تاثير هذه المشاهد على
صوره الرئيس الروسي في الداخل الروسي صحيح
ميسون يعني الاطواق الامنيه الذي التي
يتحدث عنها الروس دوما وان الجيش الروسي
والامن الروسي قائم على حمايه المدن نلاحظ
بان هناك اختراق يصل الى الكرملين وهذا
الشيء خطير نوعا ما بالرغم من ان موسكو
اعلنت مباشره بعد انتشار هذا الفيديو وبعد
الاعلان عن هذا الخبر بان عيد النصر
واحتفالته ستجري بالوقت المحدد لا تعديل
ابدا على خطا سيشارك فيه وكاميرا العربيه
ستكون حاضره ميسون في هذا العيد وستبتعد
امطار فقط عن المنصه الرئيسيه الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه تقول لا علاقه لنا بالهجوم على
الكرملين من يمكن ان يستفيد من مثل ما حدث
غير اوكرانيا وحربها الان يعني المستفيد
من هذا الموضوع هم اطراف كثيره ميسون
بصراحه يعني موسكو قد تصعد من عمليتها
العسكريه اليوم في الاراضي الاوكرانيه
يعني تجاهلا او يعني للابتعاد عن عن موسكو
يعني المستنكره لهذا الفعل قليلا قد تتجه
اوكرانيا نحو هذا التصريع لكن كما تحدث
طبعا منذ قليل الاستاذ بسام البني قد تكون
اطراف خارجيه لها مصلحه في هذا الشيء يعني
اوكرانيا ميسون يعني في الاول والاخير
موسكو ترى اليوم في نظام كيف العدو
الرئيسي الاول لها باعتبارها ان يعني هي
نقطه تلاقي جميع الخطط الغربيه في مواجهه
موسكو محمد البابا تحدث بشكل يعني عن نقطه
مهمه جدا وان هذه الطائره من دون طيار
يعني عبرت مسافه طويله زادت عن الالف كيلو
متر هي المسافه نعم غير معروف استطيع هذه
الطائره موجهه من الداخل وهذا طبعا هي
مشكله بحزاتها طبعا اخطر
لدى
السلطات الروسيه القدره على متابعه سير
هذه المسيرات او لا بكل بساطه ميسون هي
امنيه يعني حول العاصمه الروسيه موسكو
وحول المدن الكبرى الجميع يعرف ان غالبيه
الطائرات من دون طيار التي اسقطتها موسكو
في العمق الروسي كانت تسقط على مسافه 90
او 70 كم بعيدا عن العاصمه لان من هناك
تبدا الاطواق الامنيه بالعمل بشكل جيد
موسكو كما نلاحظ طبعا الكثير من المباني
ومنها العسكريه وزاره الدفاع بعض المدارس
وغيرها من الابنيه الحكوميه على سقفها
طبعا انظمه لدفاع الجوي لذلك طبعا ما
نشاهده في هذا الفيديو من اطلاق لهذا
الصاروخ واصطياده لهذه الطائره من دون
طيار ليس بالمشكله الكبيره لكن هل المشكله
تكمن في انه يحدث فوق الكرملين بجانب
الساحه الحمراء التي طبعا في عيد النصر قد
يقوم بوتين بايصال رساله للغرب عبر عرضه
العسكري عبر اظهار نوع جديد من السلاح ان
كان مدرعات او دبابات او صواريخ او غير
ذلك من الطائرات التي تطير فوق السماء
المدينه وفوق الحمراء لذلك طبعا الوضع
بسيط ابدا اقل من خلال كل هذه الفتره كان
هناك توقعات حقيقيه وتخوفات حقيقيه من ان
تصل شظايا ما يحدث الى قلب العاصمه او لا
المواطن الروسي كان على يقين بان بعض
الضربات ستصل الى العاصمه الروسيه موسكو
يعني حديث مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في
مجموعات يعني التي تضم اهالي طلاب المدارس
يعني كيف يمكن التصرف ماذا سيحدث لماذا تم
وضع انظمه الدفاع الجوي فوق بعض المدارس
ويعني وبالمناسبه يعني مدرسه اطفالي يعني
على على سقف هذه المدرسه يوزى يوجد نظام
للدفاع الجوي المواطن الروسي كان يتوقع
هذا الشيء لكن يعني ما لم يتوقعه احد هو
وصول هذه الطائرات الى فوق
هي رساله تخويف ام انه بالفعل كما يقول
الكرملين يقول بانه هي محاوله اغتيال
الرئيس الروسي ام ماذا ميسون بصراحه لنعرف
ما يقف خلف هذه الرساله لابد من قراءه
الموضوع بشكل واقعي يعني بوتين لم يكن
موجودا في مكتبه في ليله او عشيه هذا
الموضوع والجميع يعرف بان مكتب بوتين
الرئيس الذي يشري فيه اجتماعاته الدوريه
ان كانت بشكل مباشر او عبر تقنيه الفيديو
يعني هذا المكتب لا يقع داخل الكرملين
وهذا الشيء كما نلاحظ من مقاطع الفيديو
حدث خلال الليل لذلك طبعا اتوقع بان يعني
صعد نوعا ما حول طريقه او ان هذا الدرون
كان الاستهداف شخصيه رئيس البلاد وزعيم
لذلك طبعا عند العوده لهذا الموضوع ملاحظه
تفاصيله قد نلاحظ بان موسكو تقوم بالتصعيد
بالرد نوعا ما تبعا لخطوره الموضوع ووصول
مثل هذه الطائرات فوق سقف مبنى شكرا عبد
الجواد على هذه المعلومات واعود الى ضيفه
على بيان الرئ اسه الاوكرانيه اوكرانيا لا
علاقه لها ابدا بما حدث تقول اوكرانيا
انها على درايه ان الهجوم على الكرملين قد
يتسبب في رد فعل روسي متطرف كيف تقرا هذه
التصريحات واوكرانيا تقول انها لم تقم
بذلك
[موسيقى]
رئيس الدوله الاوكرانيه خارجه للالعابه
لانها كما انا ذكرت من بدايه الاوكرانيه
هناك قياده
جيش تحت تصرف
القوه الثالثه من الخارج والخبراء
والقرارات الاساسيه لا شاقهم يتخذونها غير
اوكرانيين اولا الشيطان ان هذا حتى اذا هو
كانت العلم ان هذا الحادث وبلاشاك ان لا
يمكن ان لا يعطي له خبر يمشي هذا يعني انه
هو كان لا يعرف
ولكن رد الفعل بالنهايه هل يجب من روسيا
ان تكون متساويه ان كان يعلم ولكنه لم
يفعل او ان كان قد فعلا اخذ القرار بنفسه
رد الفعل الروسي ماذا نتوقع اقول لكم
ان لا يكون الرد على نفس الهدف ولا
تستهدفوا
او رئاسه الاوكرانيه
ولكن لدي روسيا امكانيات اخرى اكثر فعاله
وهي توسيع الضربات الروسيه على المراكز
الاساسيه كما
بعض المحللين عندكم الان ان هناك مراكز
اخرى على حدود مع
بولونيا المراكز
سكه الحديد الذي ينقل منها
الصواريخات الى سكه الحديد اوكرانيه وكذلك
الشيكه الحديد قرينيه والمراكز للاتخاذ
القرارات مثلا وزاره الدفاع
واستخبارات اوكرانيه موجوده البنايه وسط
تقريبا على جزيره نهر النيفر
سننتظر حتى نرى رد الفعل الروسي ولكن اسمح
لي
نقرا المشهد ونقرا الرسائل المتوقعه من
وراء هذا الاستهداف هل بالفعل يمكن ان
يكون كما تقول كريم استهداف للرئيس الروسي
الذي لم يكن متواجد في ذلك المكان
والتوقيت حتى لا يتناسب ربما مع الموقع
الذي تم استهدافه ام انه رساله تحذيريه
افشال لاحتفالات النصر او طرف ثالث يريد
اشعال ماذا اي من الخيارات انت تنظر اليها
اكثر او الرسائل التي تعتقد انت كمواطن
روسي قد وصلتك الان
اعتبر الرساله
رساله للقياده الروسيه بشكل عام السياسيه
والعسكريه
ولروسيا كدوله انه حجم على امريكا ان
يتابع الحربا ضد روسيا بالوكاله
قياده اخرى
وكلاء
الاهداف الامريكيه لان استدامه الرئيس عن
القرار مره اخرى هم استدام بين امريكا
وروسيا انا سعيد العالمي انا انا روسيا
كانت تتحدى امريكا بشده
منذ سنه اكثر
بقي طوال ذلك الوقت رغم انه الكل يقول
ويشير كما تشير انت من المراقبين بانه
الحرب هي امريكيه روسيه الا ان ال ال
الملعب بالنهايه كان اوكرانيا ولم يتسع
اكثر من ذلك هل نحن الان نشهد اتساع لرقعه
الحرب ما بين
البلدين ام ماذا
لا انا لا اعتبر ان امريكا تغير
استراتيجيتها استراتيجيتها الخوض الحروب
بالوكاله ليست تورط مركى مباشر وليست حلف
شمالي تورط مباشره اما هذا اذا وجد هناك
وكيلا امينه
ان تخوضوا المعارض يعني
تزوده بسلاح المناسب
واي امكانيات العسكريه متوافره لدى الغرب
يعطي لجيش اوكرانيين وتزوده باموال الضخمه
وقل هذا يكفي وهذا لا يطلب من امريكا او
خلف شمال الاطلسي ان يكون اوكرانيا عضوا
في هذا الحلم اما افضل شيء اذا هم
ينفذون الاوامر الحلف الشمال الاطلسي
بالوكاله ولا اي مسؤوليه الدول الغربيه
امام رو سيا امام الدنيا لانهم لا مباشره
الطريقه الحوض المعارك اليوم افضل مخرج
دقيقتين خليني اسال سيد بسام البني تعليق
اخير على ما يحدث خاصه تعليق الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه بان لا علاقه لاوكرانيا بما
حدث سيد بسام يعني اوكرانيا لا تستطيع ان
تقول ان لها علاقه لانها تخشى من الرده
فعل الروسيا كما ذكر السيد قبل قليل يعني
هناك مراكز لتجمع القوى على الحدود
البولنديه
الاوكرانيه وهناك مراكز المخابرات
العسكريه على ضفه ووزاره الدفاع يعني هم
يتوضون في اللبن كما يقال اليوم يعني كما
يقول المثل الان اوكرانيا في حاله تردد
وتخبط لا تعلم هل تتبنى ام لا تتبنى وهناك
الرئيس في فنلندا ولا احد على تبني هذا
الموضوع ربما تكون لا يعلم بهذه العمليه
يمكن ربما
الكاتب السياسي بسام البني شكرا جزيلا لك
وطبعا اشكر كل من ضيوفي من موسكو
الدبلوماسي السابق والمحلل السياسي في
تسلاف من موسكو مراسله العربيه طعمه وايضا
الخارجيه الاوكراني وكان معي ايضا في
الاستوديو عبد الجواد الرشد مراسل العربيه
شكرا جزيلا لكم
طبعا مشاهدينا التغطيه ستستمر ولكن مع
الزميل احمد بعد قليل
تغطيه حول استهداف مسيرتين للكرملين
الكريم
بهذه العمليه ومحاوله مباشره لاستهداف
الرئيس الروسي محاوله فاشله ولكن بالمقابل
اوكرانيا بحسب بيان صادر عنها تقول بان
اوكرانيا لا علاقه لها بهذا الحادث وان
كانت تتوقع ايضا ان يكون هذا الهجوم له رد
فعل متطرف من قبل روسيا الى احمد الان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات